il existe un bâtiment dans ce bâtiment
il ya un sous-sol auquel ne mène qu'un
seul ascenseur
on y trouve une multitude de portes qui
conduisent vers de nombreux endroits des
endroits bien cachés pour pénétrer dans
ses réserves
labyrinthe de feuillet de reliure en
cuir et remonter à la source de la
connaissance
il faut trouver la gardienne des clés
chaque jour chaque heure à la repentance
et loire veille à la protection et la
conservation des documents patrimoniaux
elle tient dans ses mains un trousseau
qui faire les textes sabots à de
multiples univers des siècles
d'imagination sont stockés entre ses
murs les créations et inventions des
humains sont archivés dans ces lieux
obscurs accessible aux seuls élus la
gardienne et ses disciples
à la surface isabelle et adama travail
consciencieusement à la conservation des
oeuvres écrites grave et peintes l
estampille comme on marque au fer le
papier un cercle d'encre qui scellera le
destin du document à la bibliothèque de
grenoble à d'autres moments elle nettoie
des plaques de verre support antique des
premières photographies elles assurent
toutes les tâches apparemment
insignifiantes mais essentielle à la
sauvegarde pagination catalogage mise en
cartons dévoué à protéger les oeuvres de
l'humanité elle affronte la lumière la
poussière et l'humidité manifestation du
réel qui les menacent programmé pour
agir avec discrétion et minutie leur
geste est su mais leur parole est rare
donc nous est jeune et patrimoine à je
ne me trompe pas c'est vraiment un
travail à même les collections ce soit
les plaques de verre les livres anciens
et les gravures
c'est une grande chance je suis très
satisfaite de voilà de l'est participé à
l'estampillage des documents précieux ou
bien sur un cv et autographes
en tout cas la réserve c'est
donc ce sont des choses précieuses web
je suis contente de participer à ça et
je me dis que dans des centaines
d'années les collègues qui vont suivre
voila voila il vous dira tiens c'est mal
fait on sait bien faire ses lacets
contribuent déjà au bon fonctionnement
et surtout à la préservation de ce
patrimoine
c'est le patrimoine écrit ce que votre
pas très malin mais aussi le patrimoine
de chacun quoi pour moi clichés d'une
autre origine
vraiment je me dis j'ai beaucoup de
chance de faire ce métier marchés du
sénégal d'arriver ici chaque jour
j'apprends sur l'histoire de la france
puis quand je suis arrivé dans les
danseurs lieu quand je suis allé dans
les magasins j'avais les larmes aux yeux
de voir cette conservation de m'a
rappelé mon pays je me dis mais nous on
n'a pas eu cette chance ni les moyens
patience mais peut-être la faillie la
technique où les moyens ou je sais pas
où
voilà allez et documents sont mangés par
les mites
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
partis que oui avez votre parcours vous
avez pu comparer le voilà l'enjoint la
morale
ça c'est le monde que vous connaissez le
monde tel qu'il est au début du 21e
siècle
voyez dans la matrice du présente peu
d'humains réalise que cet univers n'est
pas le seul possible
la mission que remplissent la gardienne
et ses disciples et de sécuriser l'accès
aux autres univers nous permettre
d'ouvrir les portes de l'imaginaire les
seuls qui subsistent pour quitter le
désert du réel
elle est chouette les tricheurs en plus
avec ses petites joues bien roses les
jolies à cela les joues rouges
[Musique]